welcome to the world's most luxurious
fixes behind the scenes this is your
host Sean Riley after long months
working in dangerous and difficult fixes
the producers decided Riley and the crew
deserved a break this rotates this
tranny into the Seas National Geographic
spared no expense of course there are
personal sleeping cabins along with
exotic manicures at the spa they were
even treated to a beautiful fireworks
display it all adds up to a dream
vacation there's just one catch this
ship isn't going anywhere it's another
day on the job
installing a new engine on this
absolutely gigantic cruise ship they're
on the job but like the rest of us they
don't miss opportunities to have fun too
the best times are when work and play
come together to give world's toughest
fixes its unique appeal Clarence $67,000
camera has been let loose by the
director photography Gary Russell it's
been rigged by professional rigger Sean
Riley with the ship set to sail and the
footage in the can it's time to head to
the next tough fix the vacation will
have to wait